If you suddenly have the powers
of a terrifying demon, what would you do?
You just found out the world is filled
with other demons who are hungry
for flesh
and will tear you to shreds at all costs.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do and how to beat
the demons in Devilman Crybaby.
Akira here has no idea that he's about to
turn into a flesh eating demon from hell.
Later tonight,
he's your below average school
kid living with his best friend
and high school crush Miki.
one day after class Miki on the way home
ends up getting harassed by some rapper
douchebags as Akira comes to the rescue
and politely asks them to stop
bothering her.
But of course, no one listens to him,
and he gets ignored until Ryo
hear pops up Akira's
best friend and college professor.
But something is not right
as he looks different from before,
and he even pulls out a scary gun
and shoots up the dock with it.
Ryo means business and tells Akira
that he needs to come with him now
as the fate of the world rests on him.
And like the good little boy
that Akira is.
He goes off with him
and Miki begs him not to.
In the car.
Ryo tells them
that he's just been to South America
on an expedition with a colleague to study
some ancient language.
But while there, his colleague
turned into a horrifying demon
who tried to kill Ryo and himself
and then.
Now, based on Ryo's findings, he says that
terrifying demons now exist worldwide.
But Ryo didn't mention
the only thing more terrifying,
and that is life without NordVPN.
Because why would you do that?
And also, if you're like Akira or cool
and hip now and weep,
then you don't need to waste time
searching for those harder
to reach enemies
blocked in vaRyous countries.
No. Instead, try
NordVPN's high speed 5000 plus servers
that could send your location
to any of the 59 countries that it offers
with top notch privacy and security.
I might add so you can watch anime
and support us by going to NordVPN dot
com slash how to beat anime with a risk
free 30 day money back guarantee.
That's so nice.
And speaking of awesome perks,
no, it's got your back
when it comes to using numerous devices
allowing up to six connected devices
so you never run out of screens
to get your stuff PG 13 or otherwise,
go to NordVPN dot com slash
how to beat anime to get a two year
plan, plus one additional month
with a huge government discount
using the promo code.
How to beat anime.
OK, this is way too much crazy
for me to handle right now,
and we ain't even trippin.
I forgot to bring my mushrooms, dammit.
I haven't seen my good friend in a minute,
and now all of a sudden he picks me up
out of the blue and is packing heat and
tells me that there are demons worldwide.
If our friend here is a legit college
professor, then I think it's only fair
to ask him for some evidence or some facts
or data to support his hypothesis.
I demand at least some video footage
of the natives footage
of what the goal of their research
was to better understand
the context behind what Ryo is telling me,
or a third party source to corroborate
what Ryo is saying
isn't actually just pure bullshit.
If you told me out of the blue
that demons exist, well,
I'm probably going to need
a little more evidence
than believe you just on your word.
Akira is stunned
as Ryo continues to tell his best friend
what he's discovered in South America.
He says the natives that he was studying
were actually devils in disguise
and says that they've existed
on this Earth for eons,
but only recently have begun
to show their face due
to the inexplicable evidence
he's found happening
across the world,
such as mass disappearances.
Reports of unprecedented violence.
Athletes who suddenly shown
extraordinary abilities.
Akira is shocked to find out all of this,
as Ryo claims that the government
already knows all about these events,
but that they are too afraid
to tell the world due to public panic.
But Ryo thinks otherwise, and tells Akira
that they must reveal to the world
the existence of demons.
Ryo then takes Akira to a Sabbath party
happening in a creepy, abandoned building,
which he says are popular spots for demons
to take over human hosts
once their accuracy sees everything.
And then Ryo takes a swig of whiskey
and breaks
the bottle as he came to this party
to do one thing to kill everyone.
In this room, Ryo slices
into this girl's chest, for starters,
claiming
their demons are attracted to blood.
Akira then loses his shit as he watches
in horror as Ryo kills everybody.
This guy has gone nuts.
Ryo kills and kills until people
start beating on him and Akira.
But then something horrifying happens
as Akira watches in horror
as the waitress begins to transform
into a hideous demon.
Her tentacles wrap around
everyone and squeeze the life out of them
as blood begins to spurt everywhere.
Ryo was right.
OK, this is actual insanity.
Man had a gun earlier and is now killing
people, and now we have actual demons.
But we have to remember that waitress
did mouth feed us some pills and who knows
what was in those little things?
Drug induced
hallucinations are very visual anyways,
but that can include
a variety of abstract shapes
or may take the shape of an animal
or a person.
Basically, we can't trust what we see.
Our friend
introduced demons into our minds
less than 30 minutes ago, and now I'm
seeing actual demons coming to life.
Saying they ain't real just yet,
but it's safe to assume Ryo planted
that thought into my head until we know
for sure I say, Screw real, I'm out now.
I know the most buildings by law
are required
to have at least two exit routes
until we know more.
I'd leave the building ASAP
because I want to live,
but not before
taking some more people down with me
with two options
as to how I'll conduct this exit. one.
If we wanted to play it
safe, I'd escape through
whichever door
had less people in front of it.
But on the way out, I'd push and trip
as many people as I could
because I'm such a nice guy,
this way on the off chance
that there are really demons
inside this nightclub.
Well, they can have them over me or two.
If we really wanted to make a scene, I'd
rip off a piece of fabric from my clothing
or grab a towel or tissue from the bar
and grab a hold of a bottle with it.
Then breaking it, I'd covertly
stab the nearby club goers
before immediately
running in the opposite direction
towards the exit.
This way,
not many would notice the killings.
My fingerprints wouldn't be on the weapon,
and this way
I could lured the demons away
from my exit route.
Since they apparently loved blood
so much, Ryo begins
taking shots and taking names
as he begins killing demons one by one,
as other club goers begin to panic and run
out of the club in hysteria.
In the midst
of all this, Ryo pulls out a camera
and pointed at Akira in the distance.
He then calls out for the demon
Amon to possess Akira
now, knowing that what he's about to do
will change the fate of the world.
Chaos has taken
hold of the bloodstained room
as more and even more demons transform.
The carnage gets only more horrifying
as Ryo than becomes overwhelmed
by the sheer number of demons
and becomes trapped.
Ryo calls out for accuracy
name pleading for him
to help him and to top off the bad news.
A demon has just spotted
Akira Tasty flesh.
Akira runs at full speed away
from the Demons terrifying fact mouth
as the demon gets closer and closer.
But then Akira transforms
into the most terrifying demon in the room
and rips right through the pursuing demon.
Ikaros Will is too strong to be possessed
as he roars menacingly
to let the room know that he's not human
nor devil.
He is devil man.
Ryo watches in amazement as his newest
creation kills every demon in that room.
The next day, Akira goes to school
a changed man as his human height has
doubled, as well as his facial appearance
looking more menacing than ever,
but also more seductive as these girls
can contain themselves around this stuff.
His appetite has become ravenous,
and all of his urges are more prominent
than ever.
His speed and athleticism
as a runner has also increased tenfold
as people comment on how he's become this
school's newest track star, not realizing
that this transformation will come
at a horrifying cost in the coming days.
Holy Bull, SEC.
This is insane.
What the hell did Ryo get us into and what
the hell is Akira doing back at school?
Like, nothing happened.
The most life altering thing
happened to me at that club.
I take a week off from school,
maybe and spend some time looking into
what the hell is actually going on.
I'd start by going back
to where it all began
to see if what happened really did happen
or not, and I talked to Ryo himself.
I'd also begin
looking into experimentation
with my own so-called powers, seeing just
what the hell
I could do, and studied the concept
of what it means to be a devil man itself.
And while we're on the topic of devils,
then you can bet you'll find
behind that the myths and legends
sprinkled
around different religions
actually did happen, too.
I'd get more involved
into religion than ever.
I would begin studying vaRyous
religious texts that talk about demons,
the concept of being possessed by demons
because the demons at the club
didn't seem to have control
over their transformations or behavior.
But I do, which means
I got something that they don't,
and we need to figure out
just what the hell that is.
As the last thing I want to do is to lose
my free will to the demon inside of me.
Miki asks him to join her
in an upcoming relay happening soon,
and he agrees on the way home.
She also thinks Akira for helping her
stand up to those rapper douchebags.
Later, Akira goes back to the dark
to collect Miki's bag
that she left the other day,
and those same rappers
confront him to give him some shit .
But Akira isn't playing around as he then
in one swift motion, knocks them all out.
Stunned at his own powers,
he realizes that he's stronger
than he looks
and begins to question his abilities
when all of a sudden he sees Miki
and realizes that she saw the whole thing
embarrassed and ashamed.
Akira, like the super speed demon
that he is, runs away at lightning speed.
OK, realistically,
there's no way our close friend
and housemate would believe that
this guy is anything but abnormal.
He's gains not only more than a few inches
in height, but in speed.
Athleticism, strength,
facial phenotype, as in his face,
has completely changed as well.
And now, even worse,
Miki has seen us
obliterate the these rapper douchebags
with one swift hit, which was very sweet
unless she was an idiot.
There's no way she would believe that
we just changed like that,
and there's no way we can tell her
what we are really just yet.
And this goes for anybody else
who speculates about us
as now we're pretty popular
and people naturally have questions
we would need to tell her
a convincing, believable lie
that would detract from the truth
that we're actually a devil man.
I would tell Miki that
she's right about me suddenly changing
and blamed the cause of my sudden jump
in high speed and strength.
two and a.
Steroids and also plastic surgery,
I would claim that I'm juicing
and blasting all types of performance
enhancing drugs,
altering speed, amount of muscle mass
reflexes, endurance
and even facial bone structure,
which does happen when used in excessive
amounts for prolonged peRyods of time
and also a high school or even college
student would likely know what the hell
I'm talking about exactly.
However,
this lie could be convincing enough,
and this could also throw off
any immediate suspicions
that she might have right now.
Until we know more about our situation,
we should keep her in the dark.
Akira then heads home as he comes
across a bike left behind by Ryo,
and he takes it.
He needs to find out from Ryo what's going
on, as everything has now changed.
Akira then meets Ryoat
his house as Ryo tells him what happened
last night was real and that he is now
the world's mightiest defender devilment.
Akira still can't believe it, as Ryo
tells him that he has the heart of a human
but the abilities of a devil.
And it's because of his strong willed
that he was able to remain as himself.
But Ryo is worried about the world
finding out about him
and offers his place to him,
saying he can stay here whenever he wants
and that he should eat all of his meals
here as he's prepared to help satisfy
the ravenous, carnivorous appetite of his
feeding him a special diet of pure meat.
Real also has a new job for him,
the most terrifying job in the existence
of mankind and one that will help
kill everyone he loves.
Meanwhile, at this Sabbath gathering,
we see white haired girl who is a demon
and her assistant
as they conduct horrifying experiments
on humans and demons testing the demons
capacity of free will as they try
to resist killing human test subjects.
Back at Arcturus House, Akira catches
Miki talking with the same photojournalist
from earlier who is trying to convince
Miki to take some risque photos tomorrow.
But Akira thinks he's
taking advantage of her innocence.
Miki thinks otherwise,
but doesn't know that this ignorance
will cost her a great deal.
The next day, Akira and Ryo drive around
as they hack into the police database
to try and find unsolved crimes
within the area
that show
some evidence of demon interference.
And they eventually drive to the area
where many deaths have occurred right
into the very same area
where white haired girl was earlier.
Here they find demons feeding on humans,
as I could read, then yet again
turns into a menacingly large demon
and kills all the other demons on site.
But Ryo
then notices that a photojournalist
has spotted him as devilment,
and he runs off before they can catch him
with footage showing the very existence
of Akira as a devil man.
Holy Moly, this isn't good.
It's noted that we are going
after demons in public areas
where it's conceivable that we'd run
into other people in the process.
Just basic common sense,
as who knows what could happen
if the world found out
that we are a devil man
and this would likely cause further
negative repercussions
extending down towards our family
and friends such as Miki.
Keeping our identity
a secret should be our number one
goal, and Akira
should have assessed that area
better with his heightened senses
and looked around before attacking to see
if there were any humans present
to begin with.
Some reconnaissance would have been nice.
It's not like he was pressed for time
as the only other human there.
Besides, the photojournalist was
already dead and being devoured by demons.
He could have taken his time instead of
just revealing himself, staying back
to assess the situation for a longer time
peRyod before showing his face
during the fight.
With those demons,
I would have calculated
and weighed the risks between killing them
and letting the photojournalist escape,
as is in the bigger picture.
The photojournalist releasing
those images would have affected us more
severely than letting these demons go.
And besides,
we could have killed them later.
After the brutal carnage, Ryo
then says that he'll put a stop
to the photojournalist
before he releases that video, telling
Akira that his secrecy as a devil man
is the most important thing in the world.
My how nice of him to care about us.
Back at the office,
the sleazeball photojournalist shows
the video of devilment to the boss,
but he thinks it's fake.
This pisses the photojournalist off,
who declares in the car
that he'll release it himself.
Photojournalist Man then calls Miki up
and invite her to his place for a shoot,
but he plans to find out
more about Akira from her.
Just then, some purple demon goo
that followed him
begins to fill the entire car,
drowning the photojournalist
entirely taking over his soul.
But this guy wishes he was dead
as his horror show is just the beginning.
Back upstairs, the boss
then picks up the phone and dials
White-Haired Girl as he informs her
that the photojournalist found evidence
of Amon inside devilment and tells her
that he'll try to confirm it for her soon.
This exercise white-haired girl as she
then goes outside to have some personal
fun as she turns into a horrifying ghoul
that will soon have her way with Akira.
The two boys
then show up at the photojournalists house
as they find the footage
and delete it and pay an annoyed mother
who also lives there.
After that, they find the location
of the photojournalists studio
and head their ass up at the studio.
Miki shows up to the photojournalists
apartment
as she runs in horribly
soaked to take a bath real quick.
But the photojournalist has other plans
as him and his boss
then begin taking pictures through
the wall as this creep then shows .
Up near the bathroom door
and then uses the liquid goo
from within him
to fill the room and possesses her
just then, Akira shows up as a now
possessed Miki opens the door to greet him
before seductively undressing
right before him
and hugs him as the boss
guy tries to kill him but is shot by Ryo.
Miki then runs away,
but Akira is too quick and ends up
getting the demon
to leave the body of Miki
before killing it.
Running back in with an unconscious Miki,
Akira then witnesses reassuring shooting
the barely conscious photojournalist
right in the head, saying that
no one can know about his secret No. one.
OK, we have a seRyous problem here.
Ryo just shot an unarmed man in the head
and doesn't even give two shits
about it, either.
He's truly insane
or thinks he's in the right or both.
And if it's both,
I think we have a big problem.
The definition of insanity is exhibiting
a severely disordered state of mind
where an individual is unable
to think any clear or sensible way, which,
if this is the case, simply means
Ryo needs some seRyous help.
However, if he's thinking clearly,
this means something far worse.
This means that he thinks his cause is
just and means that as a man with a cause,
he'll do whatever
it takes to achieve his objective,
which in this case is to kill all demons
and anyone who finds out about us.
He's stuck in his ways
and means that we won't be able
to convince him anytime soon.
And did I mention this also means
our family is in danger
if they find out about our secret
and Miki is right here with us,
which means we either need to run
or kill him right here right now, weighing
the options , I'd snap his neck right here
and now.
Friendships mean little
when we've got a psycho
who's rebellious cause will likely cause
the death of many other innocent people.
Not that I care about that, really,
but he might kill me
if I don't agree with him
or go along with this plan in the future.
I'd snap his neck, pour a beer in his name
and say, Call it a day.
This guy is crazy.
With the photojournalist dead,
Akira is stunned as Ryo even mentions
that he bombed his house,
killing this guy's mother in the process.
But the horror show isn't over as Ryo
got one more person on his kill
list?.Miki Akira's face drops pale
as the love of his life
gets in between Reels pistol and Oculus's
arms.
Ryo gives Akira a choice, either
live with him or die with her.
But Akira ain't having none of his shit
and defense are demanding
she lives elsewhere.
A lady plans to take a plane
to travel back to Tokyo.
This lady as accurate as mother.
But what she doesn't know
is that by tomorrow, her life will end
and there's nothing Akira can do about it.
The next day,
Miki wakes up and fails to remember
what happened yesterday,
thinking it was all a dream.
And thanks to Ryo hacking her phone, her
GPS location shows that she was at home
the whole night
back at the photojournalists house.
Now a crime scene Mr.
Goatee and white haired
lady showed up looking for Akira
getting closer by the day at the airport.
Akira as mom gets off the plane
as she gets into an airport bus,
but then she notices her husband's face
among the sea of passengers.
Only one problem.
He's a demon,
and that's when the horror show begins.
Left and right people began getting
horribly butchered as gallons of blood
litter the floor
and paint the walls thick with it.
The mom begs to be spared,
picturing her son
Akira, in her last moments
as she gets impaled by a demon tail.
Akira's mom is dead.
Now we were trapped in the bus
from the start,
but could have used the dozens
of other people in front of us
as time spent, where we could have
either done two things.
first, once the terror started happening
in the bus from the front,
I would have used this opportunity
to grab the emergency hammer,
usually located from the side panel
on the inside of the bus.
Then I would have used its sharp, narrow
point to puncture
a hole in someone's neck or body,
causing them to bleed out in the process.
Oops.
At this point,
the crowd was already panicking,
which would have allowed me to do this
without drawing
too much attention,
after
which I would place the dead person's body
above mine pretending to be dead
and covered in our victim's blood.
Think of it like a bloody camouflage.
The chaos of everyone
running around inside the bus
meant
that we could have had a possible chance
of playing dead before the demon
got to the back of the bus,
laying there until the terror was over
or until the demon got off the bus.
And the other option,
which is way less more appealing to me,
is that
we could have gone up against the demon.
But it's just us and an emergency hammer
and I'm an old lady.
I don't think my odds are good.
Akira then waits with Ryo at the terminal,
and they get word
that planes have been suspiciously
delayed.
As Ryo and Akira sense something is wrong.
Ryo then pinpoints the mom's location
and they rush off.
Turns out the mom's location is deep
within an airport plane hangar
as Akira enters with Ryo both on edge.
Agora then sees his mom sweet face
amidst the darkness.
She's OK,
only something is off as he comes
face to face with the most horrifying
demon he's ever met,
and this demon is wearing his mom's face
wearing her death mask.
This demon carries the death.
Masks of every victim is killed,
including little children, and Akira
realizes that this demon is his dad.
This stuns poor Akira as he tries
to make his dad like him a devil mat.
But the dad's willpower
isn't as strong as Akira,
but he manages to chop off his own head
with the last bit of his willpower
using his own tail.
Unfortunately for him,
this demon is tough and remain
standing and angry until Akira Fire.
Finally kills him, rating him of a father
and mother forever.
A few nights later,
Akira stops by Miki's window
as his primal urges are taking over him,
making him want to mate and kill everyone.
But in the nick of time, resist
telling Miki and goes back to his room
to release some inattention.
If you know what I mean.
OK, if I'm accurate, then
that means we got some seRyous pent up
energy broiling inside us right now.
And the longer we stay around people
we care about, the worse off
they may be if I slip up,
which means we're in trouble.
If I was Akira, I'd
either move out to psycho REOs apartment
where worst case scenaRyo,
we end up eating him.
Not a bad move, in my opinion, or
we book a motel and make Ryo pay for it.
I like that option.
I'd also consider
the fact that due to our devil's side,
we are exhibiting traits and natural
to our innate, demonic biological factors,
such as having an insane
craving to mate and kill.
If we're losing control to our inner
demon,
I'd imagine
it would be due to our complete neglect
of carrying out what is now innately
embedded into our DNA, such as the need
to hunt and kill as a demon species,
just like a drug addict without a fix.
The fact that we haven't killed
anyone in a while
could be causing us
to lose control of our inhibitions,
which means we should go get our fix
before we lose complete control.
I take the night if I was accurate to go
find some fresh flesh to devour or kill.
But now Akira is in trouble,
as elsewhere, Mr.
Goatee and white haired girl have found
out his identity and are coming for him.
And to add more bad news.
There is a secret demon council in Tokyo
and they've been noticing the increasing
number of demon deaths recently,
and thanks to Ryo, they are now on edge.
They must find out
who is causing this before it's too late.
Later,
Ryo talks about a new athlete at school
who suddenly became
the new track superstar,
and he thinks that
he is a demon in disguise.
And it is this demon
that shall be revealed
to the world as the globe will find out
the existence of demons within a week.
Ryo is planning to expose him
during the tragic event
that Akira is set to run with Miki,
but he's got other problems to deal
with first, namely Akira, as he shows up
to his place covered in nasty fluids.
Thanks to his rough night Ikaros,
demon cravings are only getting worse
as he's
struggling to control his own humanity.
Ryo then tells him to go find some sort of
vice to distract himself with be it
drugs, women, gambling anything will do.
My suggestion would be to join squad game.
Akira, barely functioning,
heads down to Tokyo's cheeky red
light district as he notices White-Haired
Girl, but Akira doesn't recognize her
as she guides him inside for some fun.
Once inside
and during the session, White-Haired Girl
then begs him to say his name
as she begins transforming into a sadistic
demon , whisking Akira away in the sky,
begging the demon inside him.
Her one
true love Arment to come out from him.
But Akira defies
her wishes and turns into a demon,
escaping her clutches
as he falls from the sky.
But Akira knows
this battle isn't over, as White-Haired
Girl then charges at him as Mr.
Goto watches in the distance.
But Akira proves to be a worthy opponent
as he nearly defeats white haired girl
before Mr.
Goatee angrily
turns into a horrifying demon and attacks
Akira as well, critically injuring him.
But White-Haired Girl is also injured
as Mr.
Goto lovingly offers his body
for white haired girl to use,
and she eagerly accepts Akira
barely awake and on the floor
waits for his inevitable death.
I guess it's always the pretty ones
that are not
because this girl is a handful,
and I kind of like it.
And now that we know that White-Haired
Girl is a bird demon
and has the ability of launching her
razor sharp claws as well as teleportation
over short distances,
this means as a devil man,
I grab some sort of barricade
or makeshift shield before attacking her,
keeping my distance
so she can touch me while targeting her
with my demon fire breath.
She's a slippery little snake
and super agile and fast, which is why
I think targeting her from a distance
could have worked out better.
But we also have to remember that
she clearly likes
the demon inside of me, Amon,
which means we could use him as leverage.
I promise her to let a man out of my body
if she would agree to stop fighting
and let our guard down.
Then, like the two timing, charming,
sneaky bastard
that I am, I would extinguish her
or at least badly wound her with my fire
breath.
This likely would have fared
better for Akira throughout this fight.
The next day, Ryo drives around the area
to find Akira passed out.
He's alive as they find out the reason
behind White-Haired Girl, not killing him.
Turns out she's already dead.
Frozen into solid rock.
Akira counts his blessings as he asks Ryo
if demons can love one
another as he swears.
He saw Mr.
Goatee profess
his love to white haired girl last night.
But Ryo says no seeing demons can't feel
any emotions except anger and pain.
Later, Ryo and Akira plan
for the big race coming up,
where they revealed to the world
the existence of demons as Ryo makes
Akira try a special drink formula
that immediately transforms him into
a demon, making him unable to hide it.
This is what they plan to do
with their next victim,
this brown haired guy who they think is
a demon.
Akira is about to set off events
that will kill every human on Earth,
and he doesn't even know it yet.
The next day at the races,
Akira gets ready to slip brown
haired guide the formula mixed in a bottle
as he confronts him in the lockers.
Acharya tells Brown Hair
Dude that he claims to have seen him
crying earlier, but this pisses brown
haired guy off and he shoves Akira.
Out of the way, but now, Akira swears
he saw genuine sadness and brown haired
guy's eyes,
which makes him rethink his decision
and he decides to not slip him the drink.
And Ryo sees this problem
ground control to major dumb.
You need to think for yourself
and take matters into your own hands.
And for that, I would applaud
Akira for not being a mindless assistant.
But if you're going to disobey rail
like that, then you've got to be
a little more sneaky.
We can't forget that Ryo is an ideological
fanatic who thinks his cause is above
everyone else's and is willing to do
whatever it takes to achieve his goal,
which I do admire.
But that's still dangerous.
He has all the cards having the resources
and knowhow when it comes to devilment
and demons in general.
If you've noticed Ryo
is thus far rarely at the front lines,
he is always at the back of the operation
if he can help it.
Pulling the strings and outsmarting
the demons through sheer wit.
Just like Emperor Palpatine,
since he lacks the physical strength
to do so and Ryo knows about our secret.
This makes Ryo a very powerful individual,
which we not only can't trust,
but we can't let him find out
that we're against his cause
because then there will be nothing
stopping him from killing our family
or revealing to the world
my devilment identity.
If I get, I wanted to play it super safe.
I would have brought along
two identical bottles
and kept them in the gym bag
that I brought along with me this way.
If I had any doubts as to whether or not
I could go through with a plan,
I could have always given brown haired guy
the fake bottle.
They didn't have the formula inside it
without Ryo knowing it was me
who backstabbed him
right before the races.
Ryo pretends to be his sponsor
and makes him drink his formula.
Setting off the destruction of the world
with this very act as the races
begin, brown hair dude zips past
everybody as Akira decides to intervene
and steals the baton from Miki
as he confronts
brown haired guy and reveals to him
his devilment identity.
And he tries to convince brown hair, dude,
that he too is a devil man.
But that's when all hell breaks loose.
Ryo sets off a raunchy video
on the jumbotron around the track,
showing violence and sex as this reacts
with the formula inside brown
haired guy system.
As he then forcibly changes into a demon,
the world is shocked as Ryo.
Make sure to zoom in just as all
the carnage breaks out, as brown haired
guy is scared and confused and begins
to run around and kill everybody.
As blood spews all over the track,
this is now the beginning of the
end of the world
Ryo now broadcast to the world.
The existence of demons
as the very same demons react miles away
at the Demon Council,
who then rage and anger
their secret has just been found out
by the world and now they are in trouble.
Ryo then finally unlocks the stadium doors
as he frees
the demon, with Akira
set to go out and finish them off.
Only Akira has other plans.
OK, while this plan worked like a charm,
Ryo and Akira
have seRyously underestimated the demons
because if they existed for a millennium,
this means that they must have found
a secret network
and have developed a pretty darn good
system where they can hide in plain sight.
Demons are not dumb,
and if I'm going around killing demons,
it won't be long before demons
start coming for me in hordes.
Throughout this whole process,
I would opt to keep my identity
a secret as this way,
even if word broke out
that there was a man killing demons
they would never have known who had was.
Ryo just showed his face.
And now I suspect it won't be long
before we have some much bigger problems.
As demons begin to come for us
over the next few months, the world
completely changes as people begin
hunting demons left and right, just like
when it was the Salem witch trials.
But like the trials in Salem,
the cost of human life is high as millions
of innocent people die in the process.
No one trusts anyone, and everyone thinks
everyone else is a demon.
It's utter chaos, and I love it.
But after witnessing hell on Earth
himself,
Akira can't stand it anymore
and confronts Ryo through a phone call.
But Ryo thinks the millions upon
millions of deaths are a necessary cost
and tells Ikoro to forget saving people
and let the world run its course.
Little does Akira know that if he doesn't
change the fate of the world soon,
then everyone will die.
Later, we see Akira
meet up with brown haired guy.
He's alive
and hiding on a rooftop near the stadium
thanks to Akira sparing his life,
and he tells him to stay up there
until the heat dies down.
As the world now knows his identity
in other parts of town,
Miki is walking alone
as she gets interrogated by some hooligans
who thinks she's a demon.
And just as she prepares
to fight for her life,
she is saved by rapper douchebag
and his gang.
But this causes a tension and the gang
runs off before the mob crowd gets them.
But Miki doesn't realize that hanging
with this group may
in fact cost her her life as Akira walks
the lonely, war torn streets.
He sees a fellow demon
getting ruthlessly killed,
and he tries to intervene to save him,
but fails.
OK, this is getting too messed up,
and now the world is out to get me
and my kind
Akira wanting to try and convert
more demons into Devil Man makes sense,
because if he doesn't,
then it won't be long before he's
eventually discovered
as the last of his kind and is killed
or has his family killed as punishment.
But I would go about it
with some more planning.
It's noted from Ryo
that parties are where demons
go to convert people,
so I will go in search of these parties
that will have the highest probability
of discovering demons and devil man.
And I would also scalp
their other feeding grounds
just like where we were discovered
by the photojournalist.
These hotspots are more than likely
going to contain demons and scare to devil
men who are aching to feed.
On flesh,
and just like the anti-coup cafe in Tokyo,
Ghoul, me being there to help struggling,
scared and lonely demons
could be a way for me to help and recruit
more devil men to my side,
rather than just walking the street
hoping to get lucky.
Ryos sits at a government council tasked
with the killing off of the world's demons
as they discuss plans for how to better
effectively find and kill demons
as millions of innocent people
are dying as a result.
But half the council agrees
and thinks it's better
to arm all the citizens completely,
but they don't realize that this is all
a part of Ryo's master evil plan.
Back at home, Miki and her rap group
arrive as they hide from the mob,
but are then dealt
with some horrible news.
Her mom has run off with her brother
for unknown reasons,
leaving a cryptic note behind.
And so the dad sets off to find them
inviting Akira
to come over and watch the house.
But he'll be a bit too late as he's
got one important thing to do first.
However, from that cryptic note,
what the mother failed to mention
is that her child, Miki's
brother, is actually a newly formed flesh
eating demon, and we know how immature
some children can be accurate.
Later, finally heads to Ryo's apartment
for the most important chat of his life
and confronts him.
But Ryo yet again thinks he's wrong
and claims that humans are weak
and deserve what they are getting,
and that only the strong will survive
to soon beat the demons.
Ryo then comments on what Ikaros
thinking that the killing of a few hundred
demons is costing the lives
of millions of humans in the process.
Ryo claims that there is nothing Akira
or anyone else can do to stop this,
but Akira is a man on a mission
and refuses to believe this.
He also says that there are more evil men
like him, but Ryo doesn't believe him.
Ryo tries
to convince him to stop this silliness,
but Akira doesn't listen as he leaves
to find more people just like him.
As I talked about before,
I think Ryo is clearly nuts
and like the evidence before suggested
he's crazy as all hell.
It's noted from the news
and online sources
that millions of people have died
in the process to rid the world of demons,
which means at this rate,
a large chunk of humanity will perish
before the demons are wiped out.
This means that Ryo's plan isn't stable
or as thought out as people like to think
we need to kill him.
Ryo, at this point in
time, is a very popular
figure and has gained notoriety
for being the one to reveal to the world
the very existence of demons
and somebody who has embedded himself
in the political workings
of worldwide governments.
This guy has some seRyous pull,
and the leaders of the world
will look to him for advice
on this matter.
We need to kill him
and put a stop to this, but in a manner
in which it will seem like an accident
and not a murder.
As if he's seen dying over all of this,
he will then turn into a martyr
and add more fuel to the world's
crusade to rid the globe of demons.
We got to make his death
look like a tragic accident.
As Akira arrives to Miki's house, the U.S.
announces that they've just declared
war on Russia,
claiming
that demons are a Russian invention.
But the U.S.
warships sent out
turn out to be run by demons
who then launch a nuclear attack,
setting off a chain of events that will
bring about the end of the world.
Then, just as the missiles
fly over the sky, a massive bright light
fills the gaping atmosphere, seemingly
killing every demon on the vessel.
As the world reports that this light
is more than 10,000 kilometers in diameter
and Ryo, not knowing what's going on
freaks out and so do the demons worldwide.
Has all communications are wiped out.
Ryo doesn't know
what's happening and can't even remember
why he turned Akira into a devil mat.
Something isn't adding up,
so he sets off to find answers,
starting with the Sabbath gathering only.
It's torn down with homeless people there
who claim to have been there
for ten years,
but the markings on the wall indicate
that something eventful did happen here.
Ryo confused beyond belief thinks someone
is covering something and goes
deeper south to find some answers
back to South America.
On the way there,
he calls up the Professor School
that he went to South America with,
but they claim that he doesn't exist.
Ryo doesn't know this,
but something much more
terrifying is about to be discovered.
Elsewhere, the dad
finally finds the location of his son
thanks to his cell phone ringing,
but what he finds
shocks him to the bone as he discovers
in horror his own son as a full blown
demon chewing on the flesh of his wife,
the son's mother.
He tries to kill him
but can't muster the strength,
and just then the police suddenly arrive,
who plan to do it for him,
blowing the dad away in the process
and shooting the son
just as the government arrives
to save him. But it's too late.
His adopted family, Miki's
family, is already dead.
OK, if you're looking for your son
whom your wife took all of a sudden,
this makes me think that pops here
should have clearly already assumed that
something was terribly wrong to begin with
if he thought clearly .
Based on the trending topic of neighbors
finding out
that other neighbors are demons,
pops could have already thought ahead
to logically as to why his wife left with
her son
and could have predicted
that one of them was a demon
as her leaving
is too much of a coincidence.
Now I get it, you're traumatized.
Your son is a team in the who.
So sad for you.
What gave you away
was the fact that you drew
too much attention to yourself
and decided to come here by bike
if you were a man of planning like me.
He may have just been able
to save the kid over here.
It's been heard that
just like accuracies, dad,
humans can overpower their demons
from time to time, just like I could.
His dad did
right before he chopped off his own head.
This means that there was some way
to try and save his son.
Now I get it, he's young and likely
not as in control as he ought to be.
But Pops here
could have stayed in the tent as he waited
for his son to finish eating his mom,
all the while trying to talk to him
into reverting back to a human.
It's messed up.
I know, but the mom's already dead,
and I'm sure she would have
preferred her son to live.
Of course, this is no guarantee,
but Pops could have at least tried this.
Rather than just yell
and make it obvious to the cops
that there was a demon in that tent.
Suddenly, Mr.
Horn's over here
appears and tries to kill Akira,
just as RedBall demon here stops him
saying the boss wants him alive.
Red haired girl
then swoops in to save him,
leaving brown haired
guy hiding in the bushes.
The demons are almost about to kill him,
and just then he quickly pledges
his allegiance to them switching sides due
to the ruthlessness he's seen in humans,
not realizing that this move will soon
cost him his life back in South America.
Ryo makes a horrifying discovery
as he sees a statue of himself.
This releases a flood of memories
within him, and Special Forces team
shows up to try and kill him.
But he instinctively reacts, killing all
the soldiers with mystifying powers.
Turns out he's not human.
Just then, a bunch of demons,
including RedBall,
show up who pledge their allegiance to him
like they already know him.
Meanwhile, Akira
shows back up and make his house crying,
and he tells her the devastating news
that her whole family is dead
and Micki breaks down crying.
Later on in the news, he sees Ryo as
he lies to the world about demons claiming
that demons are manmade caused by humans
own dissatisfaction with society.
He even reveals Akira to be a devil man
and lies about how he came to be.
He then says that the only way to kill
demons is to kill them before
they turn Akira back at the house,
then calmed the group
and Miki down before the cops come
as he leaves to find backstabbing Ryo.
But on the way,
there stops to save some innocent people,
revealing to the public
that he is a human at heart.
And cue the waterworks as he warms up
the crowd until suddenly
brown haired man shows up and stabs him,
forcing Akira to fly away.
Back at the house,
the gang prepares to escape by car
as a sudden mob,
then shows up right outside
and tries to break in with the plan
to kill every single person inside.
The mob forces their way in
as the rapper gang
fight off the intruders,
with red haired girl helping Micki escape
as she turns into a demon and flies
off the demons trying to kill Akira.
But he puts up a good fight,
managing to subdue them enough to escape
with only one goal in mind to find Miki
and confess his love for her thinking
she to be the only reason why he was able
to remain a human at heart.
It's all because of her back on the run.
Red haired girl gets critically injured
as she tells Mickie to run,
but it isn't looking too good for her
as the rapper gang shows up in a van
only with one of them dead
and the rest eyeing to kill her,
and they lunge towards her
and stab her from behind.
Drew, I'm so annoyed
they should have seen this coming from
the moment
Ikaros face was revealed to the world
and should have already left
before the mob showed up.
Now, red haired girl made the right
call, whisking Mika away.
But why did she resort to riding on land
before she was inevitably found?
Red haired girls devil man
figure possesses superhuman abilities
such as speed and endurance,
and can even jump over wide distances.
If I was her,
I wouldn't have resorted to the ground
where humans could have caught up with us
with vehicles.
Instead,
I would have pulled one right out of dying
light and remained on the rooftops
of Japan, either moving from roof to roof
and only roof to roof,
and would have settled on
top of a single roof
for at least a day or two.
The human body can survive without water
for up to two days,
giving us more than enough time
to suck it out for a day or two,
heading up
on the roofs of buildings or houses,
or at least until the heat dies down.
I don't understand
why red haired girl resorted
to running on the ground
during the getaway.
I also don't understand why they didn't
at least take one of the rapper douchebags
with them.
There was literally no point
in slowing the mob down
if Meek and the double man were going
to whisk them away to begin with.
They could have taken one other person
to function
as the man to retrieve food and water
without raising suspicions.
They wanted to hide out
for a little longer.
Akira then shows up late to the party
as he stumbles upon the most heart
crushing sight.
He sees Michy dead and beheaded.
Along with red haired girl
and anyone who tried to help them.
This enrages the beast from within
as he burns everyone alive.
He then flies off to Ryo to feed it
and holding Miki's severed head.
Akira asks why he did all of this,
as Ryo reveals to us that he is in fact
Satan himself after the fight with God.
He was banished and stumbled upon Earth
that at that time was filled with demons.
But after a peRyod of time,
God destroyed the Earth
to reform it,
and the demons went into hiding,
merging with humans throughout time
and spawning the myths and legends
that we know of today.
Ryo's mind was locked up
as he reincarnated into a little child
who is raised by villagers
until their home was destroyed,
forcing him to go into self-defense,
to escape
and finding himself
on this very mountaintop
where the boys met for the very first time
as children.
Decades back, Ryo also reveals
that the mysterious orb of light was God
himself, reforming parts of the planet
as this world slowly descends
into becoming hell.
Ryo then says that he subconsciously
converted him
into a devil man
in order to spare his life
and have him join him
after the destruction of the world.
This horrifies Akira as.
Ryo gives him two choices to die
with humans or live with him,
but Akira chooses the former and prepares
to fight him and rallies up
an army of government to side with him
in the fight against Satan himself.
OK, I think it's safe to say
that we're going to be going up
against the most evil, badass bro
in the history of the world.
Now, I'm not a betting man,
but I think it's safe to say
that we have almost
no shot of beating him.
But what we do have
is our endearing friendship
with Ryo are only childhood friend,
his only friend that he's ever had.
It's noted
that Ryo never had any other friends
or close acquaintances other than me,
not even his own guardian red ball.
This means that could still have a chance
to influence him as his trusting friend
and confidant, manipulating him
through a form of gaslighting,
which is a form of psychological abuse
where a person makes someone else question
their sanity,
perception of reality or memories.
This is realistically
our only shot in defeating him
by convincing him through his empathy
for us, as I'm willing to bet
that out of everyone in the world, Ryo
seRyously likes us.
Otherwise, why would he go through
the trouble of turning us into a demon?
He could have let us die along
with the rest of the world, but he didn't,
which means that we still have a chance,
a small chance, but a chance nonetheless.
Akira prepares for the fight of his life
as the world descends into its final days.
During its darkest hour, humanity nearly
wiped itself out through nuclear war
and destruction, as the last pockets
of humanity remain accurate goes to war
with Satan, battling it out
and using all of his
might and fury to destroy his once
best friend, Ikaros Army
slowly withers away, giving up their lives
to fuel accuracies body
until the final blow is struck between
two of the world's mightiest creatures.
After the storm, we open up to a destroyed
world with Satan and Akira lying down
stargazing as Satan drones on
about how beautiful the world is
knowing full well that the last
remnants of humanity have been wiped out.
Satan turns to accurate,
but realizes that he's ignoring him.
He then confronts Akira head
on, only to see his severed body
lying there with his soulless eyes,
gazing back at Satan dead.
Satan then begs Akira to talk to him,
beginning to feel emotions
that he's never felt before
and his ice cold heart.
He sheds tears as he realizes the only
person who cared about him is gone.
As we look on to see God's armies
descending from above to reform yet
again, a withered earth.
If you want to be cool
as the devil man himself,
then I highly suggest
you subscribe to our channel.
Let us know what you like,
what you didn't like, and don't
forget to check out our social media
and give us a thumbs up on this video.
Don't forget to subscribe.